My husband loves the spicy snacks,
so when he said he was craving Flaming Hot Cheetos today,
I decided to make him some instead of him having to go to the store.
I cooked my polenta, spread that out,
let that cool for about two hours before adding it to a food processor
alongside some egg whites,
baking powder, cayenne, garlic,
and then I gradually added in some cornstarch.
Once it was a thick paste,
I piped it onto my cutting board
that was dusted with some air root powder
before I cut that up and formed them into some Cheeto like shapes.
Set those aside while my oil heated up,
and once it was hot enough,
I fried them until they were golden brown,
transferred them over to a wire rack
before popping that in the oven
and letting that bake on my lowest heat setting
for about four to five hours
just until it was crispy and dried out.
It was almost time to pull out my Cheetos.
I started on making both my seasoning mixes.
I decided to go with the original cheese flavor
and then the flaming hot one.
I tossed my Cheetos in both of the seasonings
and lucky obviously went for the Hot Ones first,
which were gone in less than 10 minutes.